the internet was originally created by a
government Defense Agency but it quickly
became a platform for the growth of a
new industry worldwide offering a wide
range of attractive products and
services
as the web became popular with hundreds
of millions of users intelligence
agencies like the NSA decided to use it
for its own purposes an instrument for
Global Communication soon became a tool
for massive spying part of a
surveillance industrial complex
[Music]
thank you
the vast super secret National Security
Agency took to the internet like a fish
takes the water there is an often
invisible but deep connection between a
high-tech government intelligence
service and the corporate world as well
as tensions between the companies their
customers and the government it works on
many levels
first the intelligence agency works with
thousands of businesses who offer
services and provide contractors some of
the big ones are on an NSA advisory
panel and others are deeply complicit
with its Global spying and surveillance
mission
the same time that many are criticizing
government spying customers are
pressuring their phone and internet
companies accusing them of violating
their privacy
here's one case documented in this chart
shown in a lawsuit proving that a t set
up a special room to intercept calls the
government wanted to spy on
all of this collusion upsets the CEO of
another tech company Roy Singham of
thoughtworks the sad part about this is
It's really
something that has undermined Commerce
it's undermines privacy it's undermine
security it is so hypocritical what
these companies and governments have
done to something that could have been
so revolutionary so important to human
race this globalization of an Internet
economy and it's been destroyed quite
frankly by this collaboration the NSA is
proud of its Partnerships with many
companies as these documents released by
Edward Snowden makes clear the agency
has made deals with corporations that
provide data in exchange for information
on threats against their operations as
these formerly secret document show this
relationship is documented in journalist
Glenn greenwald's book no place to hide
this leaked graphic refers to what NSA
calls strategic Partnerships 80 major
Global corporations and all including
well-known computer telephone and
internet companies
this graphic outlines the specific
targets of NSA collection
email video and voice chats photos
stored data and more this document for
fiscal year 2012 shows a 32 percent
increase in cooperation from over 45
000 companies the agency reports a
strong growth in data from Google up 63
percent Facebook up 131 percent and
Skype up 248 percent we asked NSA
whistleblower Russ Tice about these
Partnerships seems as if a lot of the
technology companies that are actually
being paid to share their quote data
with the NSA absolutely and and in in
some respects I have I have a Little Bit
of Sympathy for some of these companies
because it's a carrot and a stick
now the carrot is oh by the way we're
going to pay you millions and tens of
millions of dollars
and and beef up your your bottom line
for this information the stick is if you
don't give us the information we're
going to make life miserable for you
we're going to cut back on your
government contracts and as as the CEO
of of uh Quest Communications found out
um we're going to put you in jail if we
can find some nitty-gritty thing that we
can pin on you and I think he just got
out of jail just a couple months ago
companies are often ordered to supply
information for which they are paid this
is an actual Court Document showing that
NSA requests to a foreign intelligence
surveillance Court results in orders to
the company the companies like this
process because they can then claim they
are being forced to cooperate and not
because of all the money they make so in
other words there is intimidation
actually this is really almost Mafia
like absolutely this is extortion in
blackmail
but some of these companies engage in
spying themselves challenges to Google's
use of street view cars seems on its way
to the Supreme Court their role has the
attention of Martin Smith a producer at
the PBS Frontline program
Smith says that businesses in Silicon
Valley helped create the surveillance
state that the cell phone that you carry
tracks everything everywhere you go it
increasingly tracks what you buy your
email is scanned so that advertisements
can be placed but it's creating a
turnkey surveillance state that is
that everybody is participating in it's
not just journalists and their sources
but everybody
is exposed their information they are
Google knows more about you than any
institution on the planet at this point
but these companies want you to sign
privacy agreements they they claim to be
protecting your privacy well they are
they do have privacy agreements and if
you took the time to read them uh
perhaps you could make a rational
decision but you'd never
get out of
out of your house you'd be there reading
these privacy agreements for months on
end Alfredo Lopez runs an internet
business to empower citizens you're a
customer of a company you sign a privacy
agreement with them they want you to you
know they they have an implied contract
with you to to actually ensure that your
data is treated confidentially in
private right but they've broken that
haven't they many of them they broke
they've broken it and they also re you
have to really be careful Google
collaborates with the US government it's
on a bunch of committees with the US
government and it's privacy and data
protection agreement is has more holes
than a piece of Swiss cheese so they can
do literally anything they want with
your data in fact
Gmail Google writes into its Gmail
agreement the ability to actually read
your email
they claim it's for marketing purposes
but the same apparatus they use to read
your email can also be used by some
government official to figure out what
um you know what it is you're talking
what is you're talking about and who it
is you're talking to so this is a
Battleground isn't it uh between you
know the the desire of people to
communicate without being spied on and
the insistence by the government to spy
on them that is correct the companies
require privacy agreements like these
that customers think protect them but
many of these Agreements are written by
lawyers who know how to conceal or
sanitize their real meaning the language
is deceptive rights critic wolf Richter
they're all doing it they're part of the
enormously hyped bubble of Big Data
whose business model is to collect and
monetize your personal information which
has become part of a new asset class and
seeing this the NSA is playing of data
NV at the same time initially at least
most of the big companies would not
discuss their involvement or deny it
Larry Page of Google said press reports
that suggest that Google is providing
open-ended access to our users data are
false period
Facebook's Chief security officer Joe
Sullivan said we do not provide any
government organization with direct
access to Facebook servers later
Mashable reported Google Microsoft Yahoo
and other Tech Giants knew of the
existence of the secret NSA surveillance
program prism nsa's general counsel says
tech companies were aware of prism they
just didn't know it was called that
early on in the debate there were some
statements by companies who may or may
not have been involved in
the program saying well we never heard
of prism
but whether they ever heard of prism any
company that was from whom information
was being obtained under 702 knew that
it was being obtained
correct prison was just an internal
government term that is a result of the
leaks became a public term but
collection under this program is done
pursuant to compulsory legal process
that any recipient company would have
received according to Tom gelton a
correspondent to the National Public
Radio the NSA and many companies signed
on to an ESF enduring security framework
to work together in a mutually rewarding
way as part of What's called the
enduring security framework Chief
Executives of top U.S corporations are
brought to Washington two or three times
a year for a one-day classified briefing
for each session the CEOs get special
top secret clearances so they can be
told about the latest in cyber Weaponry
they can then go back to their companies
and take steps to deal with the threats
they hear about threats they may not
previously have taken seriously suddenly
tech companies began spending Millions
to boost their images right now we we
exist in in a surveillance State it's I
have no doubt in my own mind that we
have you know the corporate uh players
and the governments the government spies
have put in place a mechanism where they
can monitor almost everything uh at real
time
um and and to to assume that our secret
policies you know which are judged by by
courts that are secret uh and and issue
mandates that are secreted to believe
that the secret mechanism will safeguard
us from devolving into a police state I
think is really the height of
recklessness Al Jazeera published emails
showing a close personal relationship
between Google execs and NSA no wonder
journalist Glenn Greenwald says there
almost is no division between the
private sector and the NSA or the
private sector and the Pentagon when it
comes to the American National Security
State they really are essentially one
here's just one list of NSA private
contractors and this is PR this goes
back before 9 11. the NSA was
increasingly in the in the internet age
was increasingly going out to the
defense
military industrial defense
intelligence complex
and
granting very very large contract
vehicles in the billions and billions of
dollars to quote unquote solve the big
data problem to solve the intelligence
problem of of the digital age
former NSA executive Thomas Drake told
us a less expensive in-house
surveillance program was later junked
and replaced by one built by a private
contractor saic at a much higher cost
the dark secret right which I have
continued to talk about is at the very
best of American in June innovation has
already solved the problem they just
chose to ignore it
one particular program is called thin
thread
and it was developed for just over three
million dollars but it didn't stand a
chance against a program called
Trailblazer which was four billion
dollars when it was awarded with great
Fanfare as a flywheel contract the
flagship program in which would take NSA
into the digital age
and that was in the spring of 2000.
in fact I was again told by my
the number three who are reported to
says you know
you got to be at least 10 million to
even get noticed and two you know thin
thread was came out of a it was a
signals
we call it signals intelligence
automation Research Center now otherwise
known as sarc which is it was really a
a
center of excellence
for but it was internal internal had
about a dozen people right
and guess what it was replaced by a well
four billion dollar project that four
billion dollar project had been already
awarded it was the corporate solution
you weren't you did not challenge the
corporate solution even though the the
acquisition regulations the contract
regs require you to determine if there
are any alternatives or existing
Solutions
that that that meet the requirements
they just because you're Outsourcing
this is a choice a certain another
critical strategic decision that was
made by General Hayden which was we're
going to buy the solution not make it
there was no in between
working for spy agencies can become a
company's profit Center the conglomerate
that Edward Snowden worked for
reportedly made over a billion dollars
servicing defense agencies like NSA
Silicon Valley is escalating pressure on
President Barack Obama to curb the U.S
government surveillance programs that
vacuum personal information off the
internet and threaten the technology
industry's Financial livelihood a
coalition that includes Google Apple
Yahoo Facebook and Microsoft's lashed
out in an open letter printed Monday in
major newspapers The Crusade United
eight companies that often compete
fiercely against each other but now find
themselves banding together to limit the
potential damage from Revelations about
the National Security agency's snooping
on web Surfers as exposes of the
corporate role mounted foreign companies
no longer wanted to do business in
America
there are reports rolling in saying that
U.S businesses are feeling Fallout
overseas from the NSA spying Revelations
you normally wouldn't make the
connection but other countries are
actually thinking twice now about buying
goods that are made by U.S companies
even Julian Assange of WikiLeaks
commented on how American companies were
being hurt
you know I've been involved in tech
industry for a long time I know my
friends in the US are really hurting as
a result of NSA of what has happened in
the NSA as far as the outside world is
concerned the United States has become
an archipelago of coercion where any
person you were dealing with in business
at Google or Facebook or Yahoo or a
telecommunications company might have
become secretly an agent of the National
Security Agency because they're ordered
to do so by the fisa court and they're
forced to keep that secret or through
the mechanism of national security
letters one study reported that the U.S
cloud computing industry could lose as
much as 36 billion in business
even as companies challenged NSA access
a top secret court that oversees
surveillance as time and time again
ruled for the NSA some companies like
Microsoft published a secret internal
manual to show employees how to
cooperate with government requests this
one was leaked
this manual shows that the company set
up a special portal for government
agencies to make requests Google decided
to publicize the growing number of
requests for information they were
receiving to show how transparent they
are then for PR reasons many companies
began pressuring the government publicly
to reform NSA you know so frankly I I
think that the the government blew it
right I think that they blew it on
communicating what they were basically
the balance of what they were going for
are here with this
so um
you know we the morning after this
started breaking
there were like a bunch of people asked
them what they thought it would look and
the government's comment was oh don't
worry basically we're not spying on any
Americans right and it's like oh
wonderful yeah it's like that's really
helpful to companies who are trying to
serve people around the world and
they're really going to inspire
confidence in American internet
companies it's like thanks for for going
out there and being really clear about
what you're doing
um so I think that that was really bad
some companies are now defying the NSA
others say the government is
irresponsibly blaming them unfairly
the tech industry is less thrilled that
the White House is shining a light on
their data collection practices through
its Big Data report companies issued
statements urging the White House to
turn its attention back to how the NSA
collects private data criticizing them
they say is irresponsible I mean we
haven't had this kind of arrogance of
American corporate government language
in my opinion since the 50s you know
when it's what's good for General Motors
is good for America and I think it's
time that the businesses in the rest of
the world took notice of this
monopolization by U.S corporations and
said this is not good for our countries
it's not good for our clients it's not
good for our customers it's not good for
the world at the same time they've made
videos like this to show the public how
they handle requests for information on
their customers
[Music]
in the course of a criminal
investigation sometimes the government
requests information on Google users
here's how we protect users information
from excessive requests while also
following the law let's say the federal
authorities want information from Google
about user Hughes on it 22. Google
protects your rights by upholding the
Fourth Amendment the law requires
authorities to use a search warrant when
seeking private content like email if
there is enough evidence to support an
application for a search warrant the
investigator heads to court
the judge inspects the application and
if satisfied issues a search warrant to
Alfredo Lopez videos like this give the
impression that these companies are
being sensitive to customer concerns
they say a range of things most of the
time the people that we interact with in
the bodies that I'm with and when I go
to different activities that you know
with hot seatazzi people where they pay
they pay for your lunch and dinner
um they say you're right Alfredo and
we're working on that or it's another
see everything is so compartmentalized
and divided that it's a self-protection
they can protect themselves
they also here is the problem to see the
picture this way you have to have the
politics to see the picture and that's
what I keep saying to people that I talk
to all the time I think as a somebody in
the tech sector something's more
upsetting to me is the lack of vigilance
in the first place of the corporations
and their hypocrisy in the defense of
this and they have no real plan to put
pressure on the United States government
or International bodies to protect their
other citizens listen we're a global
business you know I operate in 30
countries we have people working I think
in 15 countries right now we have
consumers we have businesses in all
these countries most Global businesses
do
who am I accountable to am I not
accountable to my client in India or to
my client in South Africa of course I am
I you can't pretend that you like Global
business and then you think it's okay
that one country and one set of
companies countries corporations have
this unlimited license to exploit and
spy on the rest of the world you cannot
proceed
premise that the
right to conduct surveillance against
you or anyone else it does not have that
right under the Constitution of the
United States it says it clearly and you
know all the stuff about well we have to
surveil criminals and terrorists and
everything
how you know someone's a criminal and
how do you know someone's a terrorist
why are you taking my email if these
companies can collect this information
so can the government Martin Smith's
Frontline series exposed corporate
collusion with the NSA the Googles the
Facebooks collect as much of our
sensitive data as possible but anything
you hand to a private company is
potentially governments dnsa
specifically targets the communications
of everyone Corporate America and
National
know so much about us we know so little
about them
I do see it as one of the stories of our
time it affects us all here as to
whether or not we're going to be
adequately informed about what our
government is doing and that we do have
a First Amendment a free speech and and
a fourth amendment uh that need on you
know search and seizure
we need protections they need to be
upheld
Donald Byrd teaches journalism at Long
Island University he says not all of his
students even recognize the problem our
students think that the Internet is just
a utility you turn it on and it runs
it's water electricity whatever and the
internet really has to be the same
and they're on their machines all the
time I took a train to Chicago and back
recently because my son's at Northwest
University and the kids they're all on
their screens they're not talking to
each other they're never going to meet a
significant other
many of them may not know may not care
that other people are paying attention
to what they're actually saying or
they're recording what they're saying
they're being monitored they're being
I tell them that when I go into my Bank
of America there are 14 cameras on me
watching me your cameras everywhere we
know that and so forth and I tell them
never to text anything they wouldn't
want their mother to read
is privacy dead then I mean personal
privacy I think so I think it is so in a
sense the NSA by its desire to control
everything is actually led to the global
resistance to it this is about economic
military political ideological
historical control
this is the fundamental nature of power
in the world whoever controls the
commanding Heights of the new world
economy which is the internet dominates
the economic landscape for the next 50
years then dominates the politics and
with that they dominate the political
and and Military narrative my sisters
historian and others have told me that
when you have a chance to rewrite
history you control the future this is
also about changing the history of the
past that's dangerous Victor's right
history if we're not careful
we are going to create a situation where
the history of the people who fought in
the Civil Rights Movement that's going
to be obliterated how did Nelson Mandela
go to prison it was the American Deputy
Ambassador who turned him in those facts
of History will be conveniently
discarded if we're not careful and
that's what's at stake the future of
history and the future of knowledge
coming up next combating Insider threats
the National Security Agency was set up
to keep America safe people you know
from within our organization can also
cause harm
this threat is called The Insider threat
an Insider is a trusted member of our
organization such as an employee or
contractor that intentionally causes
harm it now seems obsessed with keeping
itself safe if you see the following
Behavior you should report it
immediately to your supervisor or our
security team
among the threats NSA and other
government agencies are now facing are
not the ones they first expected or
prepared for Insider threats the NSA
estimates that as many as 4 000
employees may not be trustworthy much
information I was considered a rising
star in my office
so it wasn't like I was the disgruntled
employee former NSA staffer Russ Tice
says that after 9 11 the agency slowly
turned on itself matter of fact when all
this happened my supervisor didn't even
know what was going on so when they
yanked me out of my office my supervisor
was shocked and had no clue what was
going on so it was it was this Insider
thing that's that they're talking about
having basically employees Snoop on
other employees that's that environment
did not exist but yeah you must have
been shocked to be singled out this way
and be investigated
I was and they called me in for an
emergency psych eval and they bring this
thing up and they say that I'm crazy
because I think there could be a spy in
the intelligence business Lord forbidden
[Music]
here at their headquarters at Fort Meade
in Maryland the NSA mothership is well
guarded in a cocoon of security against
danger now like other intelligence
agencies they are increasingly uptight
forcing employees to spy on each other
here's an advisory from the U.S Navy NSA
is run by a Navy Admiral this is an
unclassified brief on The Insider threat
what is an Insider threat an Insider who
uses his or her access to harm National
Security interests or national security
through unauthorized disclosure data
modification Espionage or actions
resulting in loss or degradation of
resources or capabilities here's another
video a dramatization produced for
Homeland Security
would you recognize these situations as
potential threats if they happen to you
Ted has been employed at his firm for
six years his firms approaching a major
security upgrade that has kept him
working late into the evening so he uses
his lunch break to run a few errands
close by the office
as he talks on his cell and walks back
to his office Ted notices A co-worker
Doug Redmond
Doug appears to have just handed a bulky
folder to a man and then walked away
this is a call from vigilance if you see
something say something is its Mantra
one unintended byproduct is that
alarmist messages like this can
intimidate employees into silence
an unusual or alarming Confluence of
these situations May indicate a threat
you have the power to protect your
workplace if you see something
suspicious from one of your co-workers
say something to your supervisor human
resources department or your security
officer another Insider who became a
whistleblower says he was tagged when he
began raising questions about spying on
Americans former NSA executive Thomas
Drake was threatened with prison well I
was tagged early on as as a problem
because I was Raising
the gravis of concerns about NSA conduct
shortly after 9 11.
uh when I had that extraordinary
encounter with the lead attorney in the
office of general counsel
he said some very dark things in terms
of
what I was asking I would say why are we
in violation
of the foreign intelligence surveillance
act it has criminal sanctions he says
you don't understand
the Lord all the lawyers have looked at
it
it's all in the white house has approved
it and then he said the following which
threw me right back to the next
Administration it's all legal
and as soon as you said it's all legal
the hair standing up on the back of my
neck because this is precisely what
Nixon Nixon separated himself from the
special oath that he took which is to
preserve protect and defend the
Constitution both Drake and tice tried
to bring their concerns to the agency's
attention but got nowhere there's been a
lot of buzz from some pundits on
television saying well Snowden should
have gone inside and shared his concerns
instead of going to the public with
these secret documents those Avenues
don't exist
that chain of command the dod i g nsa's
igu is totally in bed with the security
office in the front office at Fort Meade
in NSA that's why demon go to them I
matter of fact I'm I back then I was
friends with the deputy director of NSA
and I went to him and you know I you
know he kind of acted like he didn't
know what was going on when I talked to
him very quietly
um
in private so you know I went to the dod
IG I got nowhere I went to the emergency
system protection board only because I
was a military veteran if I wasn't a
military veteran
they would have blown me off for that
because the the intelligence service is
exempt from from the laws from The
Whistleblower protection act they're
exempt and that's something you don't
hear from these pundits when they're
when they're talking they don't even
bring that up I don't even know if they
know it themselves but but the
Whistleblower protection act does not
protect someone in the intelligence
community
what about Thomas Drake I became a
whistleblower
and what I did in those weeks months and
the next few years after 9 11 was use
every available channel that was
within the government
to blow the whistle and that included
inside NSA that include the office of
General Council that include the
inspector General's office that include
obviously my supervisory chain but you
did what you were supposed to Congress
Department of Defense and a number of
others you
go through channels and Snowden didn't
and they criticizing Snowden for not
going through channels well he actually
did go through channels uh he's actually
elaborated more on that in terms of
details just that it never got anywhere
Mitchell since our interview with Drake
Snowden spoke with NBC and revealed that
he also tried to communicate with the
NSA now I had raised these complaints
not just officially in writing through
email to these offices and these
individuals but to my supervisors to my
colleagues in more than one office I did
it in Fort Meade I did it in Hawaii the
NSA downplayed snowden's charges
insisting they could only find one email
of his later NBC challenged that
response and confirmed snowden's Story
look the lawyer that I confronted
in the office of general counsel
he he warned me
he said don't ask any more questions you
don't want to go there
and I chose to fight for Within look I
was now eyewitness to this aversion of
the Constitution
I was literally my oath is on the line I
was not going to violate that oath I was
going to keep keep faith and allegiance
to the oath that oath is important to
defend the Constitution it's the idea of
how to govern ourselves or all of its
false and foibles okay historically it
is it is but you will be born Tommy I
was born yes I was and and and but I
wasn't going to stand silent and look
away because I'd be complicit unlike
Drake and other whistleblowers Snowden
released secret NSA documents he decided
that the only way to challenge them was
to show the public what NSA was doing in
its own words student didn't just dump
secret documents to get them out he
sought out responsible journalists like
Glenn Greenwald and Laura poitrust and
tried to put them in context
he asked them to protect the names of
agents at first Greenwald was too busy
to encrypt his Communications with
Snowden and almost didn't get his big
scoop the lesson of that story you know
and the reason why I've proudly told it
is twofold one is that here was somebody
who in retrospect for very good reasons
was afraid to talk to me as a source
coming to a journalist because he knew
unlike me at the time the vast reach of
the surveillance system and so he would
not talk to me or tell me anything about
who he was or what he had until I
installed encryption and that's the
broader point is we talk a lot about the
threat to privacy from the surveillance
state but how do you have a free press
and engage in a healthy news Gathering
process when the government is
monitoring people's Communications and
even collecting lists of everyone with
whom we're communicating and and it sort
of underscored the difficulty of doing
journalism and speaking freely in an
unencrypted environment ironically the
NSA had for years lobbied to block
encryption on the in internet so they
could more easily collect information
this very lack of protection later made
it easier for Snowden to download their
files what is estimated at over a
million documents maybe more only
Snowden knows for sure you know the NSA
was engaged in things like
dumbing down encryption you know making
sure that that encryption wasn't as
strong as it could be so they could
break it
and then they complain that there's a
cyber security issue out there well of
course there's a cyber security issue
because they've created a cyber security
issue building back doors into all these
software programs the government was
soon cracking down here's what happened
to Thomas Drake after an article
appeared exposing the NSA and as I found
out later then vice president Cheney had
simply issued
the call
fine and Fry
the perpetrator whoever just find and
Fry I don't care who it is make an
object lesson of them find and fried and
fried
so it's 2005. they launched the article
comes out they launched this massive
leak investigation I knew when the
article came out I no doubt there would
be investigation when the investigation
was launched I'd get caught up in it why
very few people knew about the secret
surveillance programs
they're really so what happens to you
one morning at your house
it's now almost two years later
and I'm getting ready to go to work
it's November 28th it's shortly after 7
A.M I look out the window and I see all
these FBI's streaming across the front
yard
and of course my heart's in my throat
and you know the nightmare had begun
I was tasting 35 years in prison
five counts for Espionage one for
obstruction of justice four for making
false statements to FBI agents
and now my name is splashed all over
mainstream media and the alternate media
guilty
guilty in the court of public opinion at
that time because it was so rare for an
American to be charged Espionage in the
end Drake was allowed to plead to a
minor infraction the charges were
dropped Russ Tice who also challenged
surveillance was under surveillance I
have the FBI follow me around you know
at first it was the black sedans you
know and then I I mean I got to a point
almost whereas like every black sedan I
saw I thought that's probably an FBI guy
and you got you got to get it I realized
I had to get out of that mentality too
because you know they're there but not
everybody out there is you know one of
them so
um and I learned how to how to spot them
and now the shiny Knight in armor is is
Ed Snowden because what he was willing
to do the rest of us were not was he was
willing to fall on his own sword to do
it
and when we were not mainly with the
documentation that he's provided because
he's provided the proof their
documentation he's provided which proves
all the rest of his to be correct
um and they cannot refute it now they
cannot so that took a lot of guts and he
was asked what do you think is going to
happen to you and he said Ng standing
for not good he seems to be aware of the
dangerous position he's in
well yeah especially if he looked at you
know what happened to Mr Drake and and
um and anytime anytime you put documents
out there and I find this interesting
because I've been on TV shows from way
back and they look at me and they say oh
yeah you can say that but where's your
proof where's your proof you know uh and
you know I said okay if I were to pull
out the documentation right now and it
had a bunch of classification lines on
it and I could prove it with the
documentation right here at this table
do you think that I'd make it out of
this building without being Shackled
motivated employees join institutions
because they believe in their mission
but often when exposed to abuses they
turn on their agencies and become
Insider threats
how do they keep all these people in
intelligence in line we asked
intelligence analyst Brad Sumerel who
like Ed Snowden was an online network
administrator but in the military
cleared for top secret information what
did he think drove Snowden to Rebel
something got to him you know he was
well he was working in the NSA office
where he also saw a lot of those things
happen just like in the Marine Corps you
end up in the field out in you know the
field where you see other things happen
you know some things get to you some
things don't you know
um I'd imagine he had seen enough
material that for whatever reason he
felt he was upon himself that he was
going to do what he was going to do to
share it with the American people in
some way to jump ship at the same time
yeah but I guess it was a challenging
and kind of gutsy or crazy thing to do
hmm definitely
but when people are on the inside I mean
a lot of the people who are actually
doing the technical jobs don't
necessarily
believe in in a mission in in terms of
uh you know that what they're doing is
really protecting the American people
this sometimes you know I mean they feel
like they begin to question it let's say
well I think it's sometimes depending on
what situation you're in you might begin
to question yourself I everybody found
it a little bit curious that he did it
with his position I mean he was taken
care of very well you know there was a
lot of other people working for the
government that didn't give me making
nearly that and would have certainly
never have done it at the same time I
just think he felt he was removed in
some way that's about the only thing
that I can imagine
um just to disconnect right now they
have going on what they call The Insider
threat program
where they're like terrified thousands
four thousand people on the list of
potential Insider threats seems to be a
lot of paranoia in that world too yeah
a lot a lot of big checks were written
in 2000 2002.
big checks meaning money that you gave a
lot of people a lot of jobs and when you
give somebody a job to do they're going
to do their job they overstaffed a lot
over technology and over everything so
you just got this all this big money
thrown in One Direction and everybody
has to justify their cost has all this
money resulted in enhanced security you
would think so but the former director
of NSA General Alexander says that the
U.S is more at risk today than ever
perhaps because they over expanded with
inexperienced and overpaid people he
told an Australian newspaper quote we're
at greater risk I can't measure it you
can't say well is that enough to get
through I don't know
if he doesn't know who does his solution
more spying with so many people on the
payroll it's hard to control everyone
staff members are not encouraged to
think independently the NSA has to keep
track of them as well as the people they
are spying on
compounding the problem NSA has
outsourced in effect privatized so many
of its programs reports James Bamford
who writes about NSA quote the Snowden
case demonstrates the potential risks
involved when a nation turns its spying
and eavesdropping over to companies with
lack security and inadequate Personnel
policies
in any other country the spying issue
would be relegated to politics and the
law but in America it has been embraced
by popular culture turning Snowden into
a celebrity with his face on buses comic
books and now action figures already
there are two Hollywood movies planned
about his escapades
more ominous than the risks
whistleblowers face are what's happened
to the many victims of covert U.S
foreign policies whose Fate has often
been buried in secret documents that no
one ever sees that's why this National
Security archive exists a not-for-profit
library of formally secret documents
that details the hidden history of U.S
covert policy archive director Tom Bland
showed us around their facility at
George Washington University just a few
miles from the offices of the officials
who initially kept these documents from
being seen we sat down in a room packed
with boxes of formerly secret files
we've been doing this for almost 30
years and these are the documents that
are still in paper form now almost
everything we get we either we get it
digitally or we convert it to digital as
soon as it comes in the door so this is
the real underlying documentation of of
scandals that most Americans don't even
remember well every few years you know
the meteor hits the Yucatan or a window
pops open of Scandal and then people wow
really that's what you see back there
that's what's happening right now with
Edward Snowden this is sort of like the
curtain came up and we were really is
that what's going on back there
snowden's courage and releasing these
documents has introduced maybe a whole
new generation perhaps through the mass
media the American people once again to
what their government is doing in their
name I think the real impact of those
Snowden Revelations was to show a series
of Lies by the government I mean if you
went through the church committee
investigations or Iran Contra you're
used to the fact that the government can
routinely lie but I think on the
surveillance stuff to have the head of
the National Intelligence look into the
camera and say no sir we're not
collecting data on millions of Americans
two months later turns out he's lying
through his teeth if the American people
really knew and understood what was
going on they wouldn't support it
that's an open question because the main
thing the American people seem not to
support of all the surveillance was just
the hoovering up of all the phone calls
the big metadata collection system where
every phone call for the last five to
eight years sits to from date time
length sits in a set of computers out at
Fort Meade Maryland
the other parts of the surveillance
State though it seems like the American
people do support or would support if
it's targeted
directly at keeping them safe and I
think that was the objection to the
phone call program that Snowden revealed
because not only was it scooping up
everything it had no connection at all
to really fighting terrorism
you know at the same time
we've lived in a society in incidents
like 911 of course have contributed to
this that's very fearful
that's kept on the edge of uh you know
paranoid is always an enemy out there
that's after us that's coming after us
and many Americans are because of that
willing to justify or financer support
efforts that actually undercut their own
freedom well I think Americans got to
keep asking the question are we safer in
the dark and about these surveillance
programs we were not safer in the dark
in fact we weren't being protected from
terrorism and the government was rapidly
expanding its power and collecting
everything it could we were also shown
documents the archive now has online
they received tens of thousands of
requests from researchers in the public
for documents and reports they have had
up to 3 million independent views so
we've been collecting all the documents
published by anybody from the Edwards
Snowden Lakes of the Washington Post uh
Guardian everybody Glenn Greenwald all
the folks publishing putting them
together with the historical documents
about the wiretap controversies about
the previous debates and then publishing
them so we've done the first collection
this is about we can now add the
National Security archive to the other
Insider threats the government faces as
investigative reporters they were once
Outsiders but now they have moved inside
inside a prestigious University to
ensure that the revelations of
whistleblowers become a legitimate part
of history and not so easy to whitewash
or forget today in America nearly 5
million people have security clearances
nearly a million have access to Top
Secret documents it's a big industry
that seems to be getting bigger every
day and yet parts of that industry are
pushing back
they are already pressing the government
to disclose way more about how many
times the government asks them for data
how much data they have to give over
what are the restrictions on them we
know a ton more about those transactions
today after Snowden not because Snowden
leaked them but because the companies
are pushing back against the government
The Insider threat is not new or likely
to disappear Edward Snowden was not the
first nor will he be the last and
there's more to come from the document
Snowden made off with including the
names of people NSA has spied on
even as some establishment journalists
turn on Glenn Greenwald and Edward
Snowden former whistleblowers like
Daniel Ellsberg the one-time Vietnam
military officer who leaked the Pentagon
papers rushed to their defense well I
think you did
a great benefit to this country by
letting us know what the National
Security Agency the NSA is doing for the
president under both administrations
namely
intervening in the privacy of every
communication of every American who has
an electronic device it's very hard to
imagine
a democracy really surviving long with
the government having that kind of
ability to Blackmail any given person
Ellsberg also embraced the case of
military whistleblower Bradley Now
Chelsea Manning who released secret
documents and this video on alleged war
crimes in Iraq
credit to human beings as a matter of
fact for being concerned not only about
American lives in American Security but
about what we were doing to foreigners
to Iraqis now Ellsberg and other
whistleblowers have joined hands to
encourage more whistleblowing through a
website called
exposefacts.org that can securely
receive Anonymous leaks precisely what
the government fears could lead to even
more Insider threats
that's one look into the future coming
up next we will have other forecasts
including Edward snowden's in the final
episode of our documentary series
America's surveillance state
[Music]
welcome to 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue one
seat of world power rest assured all of
the people out here are under constant
video monitoring somewhere
oh it's sunny it's hot uh here outside
the White House but it's hard to get
people to tell you how they feel about
the spying that's going on some may be
afraid to speak others say I can't tell
you anything because I'm on vacation so
I can't think about it while I'm on
vacation others were much more clear
about their opposition to NSA spying
it's illegal we have we have rights to
privacy whether it be in public or on
our computers or on our phones the
government doesn't have any right to to
spy on us it needs to stop
and yes yet they're doing it big time
aren't they
yep
so you can't uh you can't drive through
a traffic light without having 10
cameras watching you I mean do we not
have some right to privacy even in
public
uh I think we do I think I think our
government's gone
way left and Away socialist
I don't feel good about this you know
there's a joke now that says says the
chancellor changed just her number of
telephone
how about result choke it is not a good
thing one should know who are your
friends and one should know who are not
your friends we're trying to get some
people's reaction to this Scandal about
the NSA spying on people if you're
worried about it concerned about it
you're not doing anything wrong if you
have nothing to hide
do I mind if they listen in on my
conversations not a bit because I don't
have anything to hide do you know that
statement you have nothing to fear you
have nothing to hide the very statement
you have nothing to fear if you have
nothing to hide was a statement directly
attributed
to Joseph gerbils
the Nazi minister of propaganda
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
the reality of America's surveillance
State cannot be denied it is very real
and to critics very dangerous for the
future of democracy not only are there
protests uniting right and left but
satirists like the creators of
Australia's juice news deploy a rap
attack on the surveillance state
hold the latest weapon in the war of
Terror our greatest invention since 9 11
guaranteed to keep us free and stake
forever I give you the surveillance
State ladies and gentles our secret
wires log your key style monitor every
single number on your speed dial rewind
straight to your position with facial
recognition and pinpoint you within 0.03
of a mile while some citizens fight back
against more encroachments on privacy
the NSA and its backers in the White
House Congress and the courts are
expanding their own reach now monitoring
literally trillions of messages and even
using state-of-the-art facial
recognition software NSA is also
building facilities to store its data
like this top secret 1.7 billion dollar
Storage Center in Utah the size of 17
football fields it will store yatabites
the equivalent of 500 quintillion pages
of text
the war on terror seems almost
self-perpetuating along with its
insatiable need for Endless surveillance
even as the surveillance state is being
challenged as never before there is a
political battle over the future of NSA
spying with tactics escalating on all
sides
in fact Mass U.S surveillance goes back
to our war on the Philippines in 1901
when it was used to identify critics and
Rebels it had a strong racial component
then and critics say it still does
especially in spying on the Muslim
Community even as that seems to have
abated somewhat the surveillance program
was created 18 months after the 9 11
Terror attacks its mission to have
undercover police officers collect
information about Muslim and Middle
Eastern communities eavesdropping on
mosques businesses and restaurants while
supporters argued it was a necessary
anti-terror strategy the program created
under the watch of former police
commissioner Ray Kelly outraged many
Muslims who believed it was a violation
of civil rights what can stop the
surveillance State what about the courts
Adam liptak covers the Supreme Court for
the New York Times
the Press had some great victories in
the 60s and 70s and that's basically in
Decline and after 9 11 and with concerns
about National Security the landscape
for press Freedom Is Not Great the legal
landscape
so what can journalists do here do they
if they're trying to get information
legitimately the government doesn't want
them to have it
uh that's a confrontation or a challenge
what do they do well journalists can can
be tough and be brave and seek out
information and publish it and
unfortunately sometimes face the
consequences lipsack speaks in terms of
a balance between safeguards the
government says it needs and the
Public's right to know
he admits his newspaper doesn't publish
everything they know there is on the one
hand vast over classification sometimes
to cover up government misleads or
embarrassing episodes on the other hand
there are the kinds of secrets that
could really endanger the nation and
finding the right line is not an easy
thing but I mean the New York Times
published The Pentagon Papers New York
Times is publishing quote the Snowden
papers does that make you proud or do
you have concerns about that I'm not
going to second guess the Judgment of
the very good editors of the New York
Times but they are judgments and we
don't publish everything that comes into
our position
the Press clearly feels constrained so
as embraced whistleblowers like Edward
Snowden before Snowden sent NSA
documents to reporters he insisted they
encrypt their emails to avoid being
spied on and he even made this video to
show them how to do it okay
installation's completed let's start the
program you have two choices Cleopatra
or GPA for new privacy assistant value
on GPA it's better in almost every way
even though it's older this is the
interface your keys the first thing you
need to do is a new user is go to
preferences and click advanced mode if
you don't collect this and it's not
enabled by default you won't be able to
choose your key length you want to keep
it a stronger movable Lane
Andy Greenberg of Wired Magazine says
more and more reporters are encrypting
for fear they're being spied on I think
that's often lost as we discuss the
nsa's really incredible surveillance
abilities is that they're not unlimited
there are ways to evade the NSA
surveillance as Snowden himself said
crypto Works encryption software can
prevent the government for the NSA from
spying on your Communications and so I
think that that's created this this new
Renaissance and in encryption tools and
anonymity programs that can actually
mask or hide or create a kind of bubble
of privacy around your activities online
that still exists even in today's world
of massive surveillance
crypto may have helped but it was
snowden's bold acts that captured media
attention he was at the time only 29 a
high school dropout ending up in a 122
thousand dollar a year job he called
himself virex Latin for truth teller
after using the code name true hoo-ha it
said he spent eight months plundering
nsa's secret files the mass media is now
all over the story a survey of the Lexus
Nexus database found NSA was mentioned
only
675 times in all U.S media in 2012. that
number skyrocketed to
6955 mentions in 2013. earlier media
critics denounced the lack of NSA
investigations by the Press before
snowden's disclosures and then meager
media pickup of them afterwards today
there's been a Renaissance of
independent investigative reporting
journalists close to Snowden like Glenn
Greenwald and Laura poitrust launched
their own publication The Intercept to
expose government spying it is funded by
internet billionaire Pierre omidiar
we'll give our journalists everything
they need to do their jobs well the
freedom to travel legal protection when
they need it new and Innovative
technology and the rarest resource of
all the time and organizational backing
to develop their skills omidiar is only
one business leader now pushing publicly
for restraints on NSA spying simple
examples the National Security Agency
allegedly collected the phone records of
every phone call of 320 million people
in order to identify roughly 300 people
who might be at risk
that's just bad public policy at the
same time civil liberties groups on the
left and Libertarians on the right have
been pushing Congress to act because
many like the aclu's Ben Weisner see
congressional oversight as a joke I
think fundamentally Our concern is that
surveillance technologies have developed
so quickly and Democratic controls have
been much too slow so that's true
basically in our laws that protect our
privacy from surveillance but it's also
true in our oversight
I think that that what we learned from
the Snowden Revelations is that those
parts of our democracy that are supposed
to do oversight over the Executive
Branch have failed miserably that the
Congress that the the the intelligence
committees that are supposed to rein in
and oversee the the surveillance state
in fact do the opposite they enable it
in secret Mr Snowden hasn't lied to
anyone he did break his oath of office
but part of his oath of offices to the
Constitution and he believes that when
James Clapper came in March our national
director of intelligence came and lied
that he was simply coming forward and
telling the truth that your government
was lying and this is a big concern of
mine because it makes me doubt the
administration and their word to us when
they come and talk to us because they
have now admitted that they will lie to
us if they think it's in the name of
National Security proposed new bills
would make some necessary changes to a
handful of surveillance laws but not
significantly narrow the nsa's powers
granted by law and presidential
directives you know the NSA has
information now on every federal judge
on every member of Congress on every
other member of the executive branch
they may say it's just metadata but this
is the kind of information that could
destroy any individual if it were put to
the wrong kind of use so I think people
have reason to to be worried you know
not that our form of government is going
to change overnight but that if we don't
put in the right control
there are real threats to our way of
life while government spying is what's
being debated now private spying is also
threatening there are private companies
gathering information about the
political and and
protest activities of Americans on the
streets of of American neighborhoods
across the country and there's virtually
no regulation of that activity
there's also a private surveillance
industry isn't there I mean with their
own Technologies and you know uh and and
in many cases you have international
players like Israeli companies that are
very active right and and you have an
infrastructure built for it so after 9
11 uh the U.S government helped fund the
creation of what are called state and
local intelligence fusion centers and
these fusion centers incorporate state
and local law enforcement with federal
law enforcement often other state and
local government entities like fire and
emergency response uh sometimes even
utilities private companies and the
military all together collecting
information that's collected by the
local police in your neighborhood as a
way to funnel it up to the intelligence
community and then they have programs
like what they call the suspicious
activity reporting program which sounds
fine if something's suspicious but they
Define what's suspicious and they say
things like videotaping
photography note-taking drawing diagrams
in one case in one program espousing
extreme views if you see something
say something isn't that the big slogan
here in New York exactly and what we've
seen only uh
relatively small number of these
suspicious activity reports have been
made public but what we see is exactly
what we warned they would be that it's a
proxy for racial profiling because
what's being reported isn't suspicious
former FBI agent Mike German doesn't
dismiss fears of a police state because
he too knows from the Snowden documents
that NSA shares Intelligence on
Americans with the FBI a domestic law
enforcement agency
because of my political websites I was
visited by the FBI the United States
Marshals the Secret Service the
Department of Homeland Security the
United States Air Force and some other
people that I don't even know and
not always sometimes they just
approached me and wanted to know uh you
know what you know
content about my websites you know what
certain things meant even if Government
surveillance is somehow restrained or
curtailed private surveillance is
growing with new spy Technologies now
widely available in the consumer Market
this is your family here's an ad from
one company that sells surveillance in
the name of personal Securities and when
you're not in the office do you know
what employees are doing does it feel
like you're losing control introducing
mspy mspy is a highly advanced
smartphone monitoring software that has
been designed to help you mitigate risks
at home or at work protect your kids and
your loved ones from online and offline
dangers track their location or restrict
access to applications and websites
check their SMS and phone calls mspy
lets you prevent risks of data leaks
monitor your employees and keep track of
their productivity in and out of the
office surveillance is widespread in the
corporate sector with companies spying
on customers employees and Rivals Sam
antar worked for an Electronics chain
known as Crazy Eddie which was shut down
by the federal government for Corrupt
Practices they were using surveillance
gadgets as if they were their own NSA my
name is Sam antar I'm the former Chief
Financial Officer of a criminal
Enterprise known as crazy Eddies I'm a
former CPA and I am a convicted felon
today I advise law enforcement colleges
universities about white collar crime so
some you know the issue of surveillance
is has become a big issue but it's not a
new issue really what have been your
experiences with the surveillance state
that we live in
back in my criminal days it let's put it
this way in every organization whether
it's a legitimate organization or a
criminal organization there are Rivals
vying for power there are factions in
every organization in our criminal
Enterprise which was crazy Eddie's My
Cousin Eddie Used an Israeli security
company to keep tabs on his Rivals
within the co-conspiracy
so everyone in other words there was no
honor among Thieves everyone was spying
on everyone else yes and this private
surveillance in a way has been going on
for a long time and it's very pervasive
it's a big business yes it's it's a
biggest story than the NSA stories
really corporate surveillance of critics
or corporate surveillance of Rivals
within their own corporations in other
words Executives surveilling rival
executives
perhaps that's why in our age of
innovation some engineers and Tech Geeks
are designing a new NSA surveillance
free internet physicists are using
quantum physics to design one political
leaders who've been spied on by the NSA
like leaders of Brazil and Germany are
encouraging this effort Brazil believes
that the governing of the internet
should be multi-sector Democratic and
transparent we consider the multilateral
model to be the best way to govern it is
my belief is when you're in a difficult
situation avoid the problem because
sometimes you can't win every battle and
my belief is let's try and put our
resources as corporations in the
emerging sectors of the economies of the
world where we're helping people with
their needs and we're avoiding being
part of a spy Network that no matter how
well-intentioned by some individual per
people will end up in very mischievous
uses and we see this all over repeatedly
in history so when you can't win run to
a new corner and try and build something
new the new quantum computers may not be
a Panacea for privacy says Tech
specialist and former military network
administrator Brad Summerall quantum
computers coming out
and quantum computers are going to
change everything because then
processing data is instantaneous in any
amount
so this new technology that's coming
down the pike is going to make
surveillance and all the things we're
talking about now even worse possibly
yep
a lot worse
a whole lot worse
do you feel that sometimes the system
you know just goes off on its own it's
almost Rogue you can't control it that's
kind of what's going on now especially
with that Patriot Act still in effect a
lot of people have to understand that's
what's doing the damage is that Patriot
Act
it is new I mean they've got look money
is the driver here you know they've got
money to do everything they want if they
want to Snoop on their own people they
got money to do that Congress is happy
to appropriate money to places like NSA
but the stifling effect now I ask you
what college graduate or PhD is going to
want to come down to Washington and to
subject him or herself to this kind of
stassi type environment I suggest to you
that they're going to get the bunch of
people that I'd rather not see in high
positions of our security services
philosophically
do we become the people that we warned
others about like the Stasi of East
Germany or the KGB or you know have we
turned into a surveillance state
what we have but there's some good news
okay the good news is this
that surveillance States can't operate
without incredibly gifted incredibly
imaginative incredibly smart people like
Edward Snowden okay now if you only have
one out of a hundred or maybe even out
of a thousand technically proficient
people like this
that's all you need to do it Edward
Snowden did so
the governments cannot operate without
these very bright people a lot of these
bright people bring consciences to their
expertise as long as that's the case and
that will continue to be the case the
governments will not be able to get away
with this kind of thing so that's the
good news the bad news of course is
they'll keep trying and as I say said
before with the executives the
legislative and judicial branches of our
government all kind of complicit in this
well and then you have the media and the
corporations and all that it looks very
much like the classic definition that
Mussolini gave to Fascism and you know
there's still a lot more to be
discovered I mean because of Edward
Snowden we have access to an awful lot
of information about an awful lot of
programs but it's not nearly the scope
of all these programs plus you have so
many different agencies involved now I
think there are 16 different agencies
that make up the the intelligence
Community
much less the the multitude the
thousands of companies that are involved
in this activity both here in the U.S
and abroad not quite everywhere in a
report top secret America The Washington
Post showed that there are 854
000 contractors with top secret
clearances since 9 11 33 new facilities
were built or are being built that's 17
million square feet
the bottom line seems to be that
everyone is in the game as a very
profitable surveillance industry expands
beyond the limits of government and
Beyond the borders of countries it's not
a left-wing issue it's not a right-wing
issue per se it's it's it it goes on
everywhere in this world people want to
know about what they don't know about
and spy agencies play to that yes NSA
whistleblowers are hoping the public
will get more engaged
what lessons can we learn from this
whole sad Saga if you will of an agency
that seems to have gone Rogue but it's
gotten more money and more legitimacy as
it goes along what's the few it's in the
future for America if this continues at
this level a police day that's what you
know we're talking about right now I
think we're the the very beginnings of
what I call police state light because
the police state tries to hide what
they're doing they're very covert about
their police state activities and they
deny it and they're lying about the the
fact that they do content what right do
we have as a country to engage in Mass
surveillance of Other Nation States
we don't
Remember The Sovereign rights that are
granted all human beings extends Beyond
just the fact that you're an American
citizen that's all human beings there is
this American exceptionalism somehow
we're immune from history I don't think
so all empires have ended up in the
Dustbin of History it's very but see all
Empires when they realize that they
already subconsciously realize they
could end up in the dustbins of History
tend to project they tend to compensate
and guess what they do they increasingly
militarize themselves that's precisely
what is happening in this country
let's give the last word to NSA
whistleblower Edward Snowden whose
daring disclosures have forced us all to
reflect on the dangers of a total
surveillance society and turn the
American surveillance State into a
political Battleground
to conclude I'd like to remind you that
even if these states around this
programs were perfect even if they were
never abused and even if the oversight
failures that are all too common today
were fixed
these programs have never been shown to
be uniquely valuable
and again you don't have to take my word
for it two independent White House
panels with complete access to
classified information found that these
programs had never stopped
single imminent terrorist attack in the
United States
so I would say I would argue I would
submit to you that when all three
branches of government agree that these
programs must end
it seems clear to me
that they're not a legitimate defense of
our freedoms but they are in fact a
clear and present danger to both them
and our way of life as Americans
[Music]
America's surveillance state was
produced by Danny Schechter of global
vision
for press tv